and biden patting himself on the back
after america added 850
000 jobs last month he is claiming it is
all because of
trillions in government spending watch
none of this happened by accident again
it's a direct result of the american
rescue plan
the last time the economy grew at this
rate was in 1984
and ronald reagan was telling us it's
morning in america
well it's getting close to afternoon
here the sun is coming out
the white house is getting mocked as
well for a corny social media post
bragging about how americans will save
16 cents this year on food
at their fourth of july barbecues and
biden was in no mood to take tough
questions heading into the holiday
weekend
i want to talk about happy things man
it's fourth of july
i'm concerned that you guys are asking
me questions that i'll answer next week
but i'm just a holiday weekend i'm going
to celebrate it there's great things
happening
economy has grown faster than any time
in 40 years we've got a record number of
new jobs covades are down 90
wages are up faster than any time in 15
years
we're bringing out bringing our troops
home all right so
will don't you dare ask the president
about afghanistan as he's heading to a
barbecue that is just
unacceptable it concerns him what
concerns you
about what came out of his mind he only
wants to talk about happy things he also
said it's late in the afternoon which
means it's about dinner time for uncle
joe
so it's time to retire and head off and
think about happy things
you know one of the things i like about
this past year and look when you say the
economy is growing at a record rate
that's because once again let's remind
ourselves it was shut down
it was at a grinding halt so yeah it's
going to pick up some steam coming back
from a total stop
but politics and these debates we
normally have are kind of theoretical
you take a liberal and you take a
conservative and you say how do our
ideas play out over
decades not this past year we've had
essentially gain of function for
political ideas we have seen how
lockdowns have worked how disincentive
like high unemployment
insurance strung out over years or over
a year has worked we have
seen liberal policies play out in
reality
and and the judgment has come back
within a resounding
failure rate joe biden's policies
democratic liberal politics liberal
economics
lockdowns every step of the way it's not
theoretical anymore we have real world
evidence
these are failures and look at the
states by the way they're coming back
look at the states 15 states now have
come back to normal
from lockdown 12 of those are red states
12 of those are states that embodied
open policies when it comes to the
economy this doesn't have to be a
theoretical debate anymore we can see
the world around us
jessica i feel like will was talking to
you that whole time so dude
we were having a private moment
a private economic moment that's
literally you're the bravest man of fox
news
there was a lot of sense to what will
was talking about we do have
every month we get so much more
information and this starts at the
kickoff of the pandemic right from when
we had people
on both sides of the annually the
surgeon general and dr fauci saying no
masks yet right and then we get more
information we know how airborne it is
etc
you're right about the economies of
those red states there are also
population issues density issues for
blue states like in new york for
instance it's just very different
to manage that i mean we can't spread
out here right like i can't be away from
my neighbor
but if i live in a more sparsely
populated
red state i could do that i think that
you also need to pay attention to
a rise in coveted infection rates that
are going up in red states and that we
have a vaccination problem
in those states we have an 18 to 24 25
year old problem
and we have a red state problem with
that and with the delta variant coming
which is not more deadly but more
transmissible
that's something on our radar i see that
it's true
the delta variant but it's it people you
don't want
everyone who is in the hospital right
now with covid is not vaccinated
everyone should be getting vaccinated no
matter where you live i do think taking
this victory lap
on a jobs report 850 000 jobs that's
fi what is it three million in five
months the most of any presidency on
record
we went through the depression obama
inherited a pretty bum deal out of bush
didn't get that many jobs he should take
that lap hourly pay rise 3.6
that's more than pre-pandemic levels so
there is something to be talking about
for biden
and dagen but with those numbers also
include unemployment
rising so it sort of reflects there's a
there is a brokenness to the system so
since a lot of what came out of the
president's mouth was sort of untrue can
you please enlighten us
to the real numbers that we should be
worried about lies
what uh biden said was disingenuous i
will say that he was talking about
instead of workers competing with each
other for jobs
that are scarce employers are competing
with each other to attract workers
that is that's competition
no it's not it's got the government is
paying
three hundred dollars per week extra for
people to stay on
unemployment you have a record number of
job
openings in this country 9.3 million
job openings so the job market would
actually be growing
much faster if this extra 300
didn't exist for the unemployed there's
a scarcity of workers
you have people will be trying to fill
up their cars
over the weekend and there will be gas
stations that don't have any gas
simply because they don't have enough
truckers who are licensed to haul
fuel to get the fuel to the
fueling stations to the service stations
so when joe biden
is talking about natural competition
they actually
if you look at the states that have
gotten rid of the extra unemployment
benefits
people are falling off unemployment even
quicker in those states
it expires in september but this is all
a economy that is being propped up or
people on unemployment being propped up
by the government government
intervention and fiat
and just one more thing the talking
about 16
excuse me 16 cents less than last year
well because nobody celebrated the
fourth of july last year and it's up
eight percent
from two years ago so that's 16 cents
that'll buy you a whole 120th of a
gallon of gas
because you got seven year highs on
gasoline because joe biden's taking a
chainsaw to the energy sector in part
so speaking of that are you upset it's
gonna cost you like a thousand dollars
to fill up your defender tank as you
cruise into independence day celebration
well as you know as a former
uh professional cheerleader it's it it
is hard to be happy i do know what i'm
going to do
with my 16 cents i looked up at the
one-year cd
uh if i put it in a one-year cd at a
half of one percent by the
this time next year that 16 cents will
be 22 cents
so there you go that's going to be great
the weird thing about the economy
uh is that it's so kind of oddly
dependable that you could turn it off
and then turn it on like it's an air
conditioner on a hot day
i didn't think that would be possible
when you think about like last year and
we turned the thing off and and then we
kept the children away from the switches
and then we turned it back on it's
actually probably more like a
self-driving car our economy and the
president should be sitting in the
in the driver's seat but not really
touching anything just letting it go
but the scary thing about joe is that
he's really not behind the wheel no and
somebody else is
yeah and he's like the guy in arizona
that was like on his phone while the
self-driving car crashed into
a wall or whatever it was good analogy
emily yes you're welcome all right
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else